[Musique]
il rentrait de la ville
si tous qu'on est astucieux belle mère
le plus sérieux à jouer des mots amis
tout est ce que tu es mon ami je suis
ton ami
regarde moi je te regarde mais ma parole
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya mais tu es
maquiller je suis ravi qu'on suit
simplement aller par l'ère de la forêt
la nature ça va pas ça me touche pas le
bec comme ça qu'est ce que la jeune
j'avais l'impression que tu avais des
vestes de bec rouge qui t'avait embrasse
et oh non non je n'ai pas forcé belle
belle oui tu n'as pas vu le même nom à
ces petites de la peinture oui parce que
j'étais avec hervé legrand là nous
arrive à petit il m'a mis un peu de
peinture sur le banc c'est possible
voilà ce qu'il m'a chargé d'apporter à
tu vois le jeu des dessins voilà nous
allons nous pencher sur le plat syrie
oui remettez le dessin en ordre oui
voici une jolie séquence
alors bon tu vois ça y est un premier
dessin la wii va y en avoir un second
est ensuite un troisième
alors toi tu devras me dire et puis tous
ceux qui voudront d'ailleurs dans quel
ordre ils doivent être distribués quel
ordre logique oui logique parce que il
ya quelque chose de vraiment alors
logique là ça saute aux yeux la wii
alors à bon alors on l'a vu ce qu'il a
au passage en engageant garde je regarde
le premier quand même détaillons là pour
bien vu or berne y sont à table ils sont
à table ils sont amusantes abri attends
je regarde le second dessin voilà sur
toujours ta table ils sont toujours ta
table oui ils sont toujours à table et à
la voilà oui je la crois que j'ai à peu
près vu ya un petit bord éthique qui
dira la fenêtre agricole cela dispense
tout sur moi ton à tourner à l'autre
bout à l'autre otage en un ronflant à la
wii u
vie tu vois oui c'est toujours à table
oui tous sont toujours otages
ce jeu c'est con con alors maintenant
j'ai l'honneur de vous dire que j'ai
trouvé
monsieur patrice non moi c'est fabrice
ah oui encore une année de foot
la prochaine fois ce sera un pan sur le
bec excuses et maintenance
le jeu coûte en tant qu est ce que vous
disiez oui alors vous avez trouvé
l'ordre oui jetteront aller dans le
jardin
je le fais mais non à huy incendie dans
un état aujourd'hui tout énervé mais tu
n'aurais pas un petit peu non j'ai eu
deux gymnases dans trop manger des
feuilles de chêne abbas et ça alors ça
te monte à la tête
alors moi je mettrais vois tu le premier
dessin je mettrai le dessin dans lequel
la bouteille est pleine
voilà oui ça c'est le début du repas ces
zones il soif après je mettrais bien
entendu le dessin dans lequel la
bouteille est à moitié vide ou à moitié
plein à mon but est ensuite bien entendu
je mettrai le dessin dans lequel la
ville a épaté maribor vide voilà riz de
da j'ai gagné
il faudra vous voilà c'est tout je m'en
vais je vais dans le jane dakota l'heure
et moi je vais retrouver bell bell est
comment il s'appelle à pouss moussu
excusez moi j'arrive dans ma voiture
voilà qu'on appelle
on a tellement appelle le fabrice oui
fabrice heureusement que tu es là parce
que s'ils ont tous quand comme parent
est dans un état tout à fait discutable
alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à brice ça va être très très
difficile très difficile oui alors tu
explique le jeune on sait pas quand je
suis fatiguée c'est toi qui va le faire
aujourd'hui parce que moi je profite de
la douceur de l'air à son talent points
si le point commun nous allons chacun
raconter une petite histoire nous
représentons un objet ou quelque chose
et il y a un point commun qui nous
relient denrées chacune des petites
histoires seulement voilà alors
aujourd'hui tu veux que je te dise oui
eh bien moi je fais une paire de patins
à glace alors ben oui c'est moi qui
permet aux virtuoses du parti najjar
tistics d'exécuter de merveilleuses
figure tu vois les spectateurs et
téléspectateurs adorent ça tu sais les
boucles les saules et comment commandes
il est double double axel oui c'est ça
andorre
en dehors de ces gracieuses évolution je
peux aussi être très brutal
je peux être au pied de joueurs de
hockey sur glace et dans ces cas là je
n'ai peur de rien la blanquette bravo tu
vois là j'ai trouvé ce que je suis et un
peu exalté bourse bell bell tu vas voir
je suis la mère
couvrat docile et oui la mer la mer bleu
la mer et mr bien sûr mais attention je
ne suis pas exactement celle dont rêvent
les baigneurs
je suis la mère en egypte est un peu
tourmenté j'ai des soucis je suis une
mère avec des creux comme disent les
marins
on voit se former à ma surface des
petites bandes dès qu'une blanche qui
sont d'ailleurs très joli ça me va a
sévi à ôta bien entendu quand je suis
dans cet état je vous conseille de vous
méfier de moi et de ne pas entreprendre
de grandes traversées sur votre petit
yoyo on veut parce que j'aime une heure
alors laissez votre bateau au port et
attendez que je me plais pas grave ça
c'est pas grave
bush même si mon petit bonhomme est à
toi moi moi moi je suis quelque chose de
très utile et très très utile surtout
pour les hommes
oui ils ont besoin moi tous les jours je
suis un rasoir mais leur toutes les
sortes de rasoir ce qu'on jette ce qu'on
garde ce qu'on a vu de tous les matins
même les rasoirs électriques
je suis très doux mais il faut qu'on se
serve de moi très doucement avec
précaution tu sais j'ai même envie un
jour d'essayer de me raser cuit pour
voir ce que ça donnera il ya des jours
en été où j'ai des poils tellement
longue que ça me gêne pour respirer
il voit un jour ce serait gentil tu
pouvais me prêter le tiens ça me ferait
plaisir
u11 pas tout de suite quand même à 90,8
a pas vraiment besoin car plus tard
alors nous avons le patin à glace
nous avons la mer et nous avons le
rasoir
oh c'est pas tellement tellement
compliqué me semble-t-il j'ai eu une
hésitation début mais maintenant ça y
est je crois que j'ai bien trouvé une
lame
il m'étonne raccrocher mais formidable
une lame sur un patin à glace des lames
bien sûr la lame de la mer et la lame du
rasoir qui est le plus mais comment fait
la dc est le plus fort des choses aussi
que je dois préparer alors fabrice
attention parce que ce sera un petit peu
plus délicat a de suite fait petit ami
alors oui alors sept semaines fabrice un
jeu j'ai trouvé un mot marié a bien
travaillé
oui oui j'aimerais verrier je t'ai
trouvé un mot très difficile j'ai encore
oublié mon stylo que j'aille le chercher
à paris des lapsus écoute j'ai bien fait
mon tournevis mais j'oubliais vous allez
chercher
voilà quotas alors alors je crois que tu
vas trouver un parce que toi tu trouves
tout le temps non ça ne faisait pas
allusion tu trouves tout le temps alors
cette fois c'est un mot en huile est
détruit haïti commence pas par un l
j'aime ça elle est comme lucien mais
quoi
lucien oui comme lui cher ami tu as
raison alors après ben ahin bien après
alors après la dernière c1 e et loisy
frais et vient de lettres première de
laiterie jeter 10 ans huit lettres alors
tu fais si petit train tu as l'habitude
maintenant oui mais quand j'entends bien
parce que tu une article une pas si peu
titrait oui là et un e e à l'ouest
tu as bien entendu un e oui un oeil il a
dit oui voilà alors maintenant que les
usa est un animal opta c'est difficile
oui c'est un animal tu sais déjà que
c'est un animal c'est un insecte
or c'est un insecte au bas du dos et
rapide ford est aussi rapide que
l'insecte
c'est un insecte qui volent au wifi vole
vite à haïti veut te donne la troisième
elle est allée
la troisième c'est bien un bbq bernard b
comme bernard 3e l'aide alors maintenant
que laissait deviner il va très vite
l'insecte
il fait et voilà rapidement et jolie
quand il est beau il est très beau qu'un
secret jolie fabrice mabri qui fait pas
je m'y attends attends tu fais des
combien de lettres la 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
oui j'étais des huit lettres et et j'en
ai bien aimé ça colle pas moi j'ai
libellules là c'est sa libellule
mais comment est ce que tu écris
libellules bas libellules comme ça tu
prononces elle
ib e l ul eux il ya deux ailes la
libellule
il ya deux semaines à lyon 2 et l'ayant
mais non il ya 2 et 7 yavin ellul ah ben
non
quand tu mélanges tout on est dans un
état aujourd'hui oui j'aurais qu'il a
habité à nîmes évidemment alors
évidemment j'aurais dû y penser
libellule il vit avec deux ailes sinon
on ne pourrait pas volé bien sûr
libérons la la la la
aucun progrès élèves pouces moussaoui
maui progressait pas à la libellule ce
qui m'aidera y penser c'est que la
libellule avec ses ailes très fine très
transparente elle vole très vite elle
est ainsi l'un des insectes les plus
rapides qu'on connaisse alors y est tu
sais quand une seconde elle fait d'y
mettre un second pas facile de
l'attraper c'est pas facile surtout
qu'elle te vois venir
la libellule elle a des yeux qui
comporte jusqu'à vingt mille facettes
tu te rends compte le jour où tu en
attrapant une quartier tu me l'as
montrera à ça ça me fera plaisir mais
c'est c'est très bon comme goût ou les
enfants tout con ce que c'est bien
raisonnable non ça c'est pas si on
pensait un peu abel belle musique
oui absolument aller
[Musique]
fabrice de mon coeur vous dit que nous
allions vous que nous allions au sommet
nous allions vous mais moi je trouve ça
passionnant de regarder les bêtes les
petites les grosses qu'elles soient
sauvages ou qu'elle soit 1 hier jeudi
qu'elle soit sauvage où elle y est
voyons alors avec les notes de la gamme
je complète ce que tu à te dire c'est à
dix jeunes est une note ici je mets une
note
là c'est nous avons famille hier pour
fouiller brave ou alors donc qu'ils
soient sauvages ou famille hier toutes
les bêtes ont quelque chose
d'intéressant
il y en a par exemple qui sont rigolotes
elles ont l'air déguisée tiens regarde
le zèbre avec ses hommes sur le terrain
avec ses avec c'est avec ces raies sur
le message toujours agité toujours en
train de faire des cabrioles des
grimaces tu sais que ce sont de
véritables comédiens et ils savent très
bien qu on vient là pour les adh pour
les adh que pour les add on sait bien à
pour les odes pour les atteintes à temps
à temps pour les arabes ni voilà pour
les admirer bien sûr mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres animaux et admirer par exemple
sur un mât par exemple ce mât qui vient
en amérique du sud ils achètent chaque
état s'étant la main oui
la main avec des longues poire oui elle
peut parfaitement et tu vois dans ce
bassin rempli rempli de rempli d'eau
merci fabrice dans ce bassin rempli
d'eau vive tu le sais bien c'est
prodigieux animaux qui sont à la fois
des joyeux compagnons très intelligents
et qui semble être de grands amis des
hommes
je veux bien entendu parler des copains
mais quoi d enfin mais enfin oui ah ah
ah bah je ne bronche pas des dauphins
wii et enfin oui c'est parfait alors
puisque nous sommes zozo nous allons
nous approcher de plus près puisque les
animaux sont protégés par des grillages
sinon tu sais je n'aimerais pas du tout
rencontrer ses titres supporter un
séjour part dans la nature parce que ce
ne sont pas des ennemis tra la la leyre
vaincre ralala l'air vaincre travail oui
alors la fin il faut te dépêcher parce
que je trouve que tu as un peu le roi
bon bain & co j'aurai à travers un quiz
rapport ça ne vient pas alors je t'aide
baiser ne me fâche si la facilité ne
vendent bon jab on donne beaucoup de
chats abandonnés en jambes et qui aurait
pu tourner très bien sûr temps même
s'ils n'ont fait que j'étais un viol et
d'ailleurs ce n'était pas tellement non
et ben moi je joue plus non non madame
nous parce que ça tu n'as pas le droit
de faire ça voilà ce que j'avais à dire
c'est beaucoup trop difficile musique je
ne joue plus
[Musique]
les tapis les jarres pop et d'amis du
tadla qui se plaint que la vie majeur
s'est désisté et rzeszow des choses les
comme juni pas de mine war l'aideront à
faire attention les cartes à guy ritchie
ne retarde m lamy
[Musique]
oui
j'habite à jouer aujourd'hui
il a dit vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]